I don't think there is a single
process for finding investors.
I like to recommend to entrepreneurs
to stand in luck's way.
They're standing in harm's way,
but standing in luck's way.
That means you do things where
good things might happen to you.
So perhaps going to a meet up
group around where you live
where investors are in a panel or
speaking or someone that's
speak about a topic that's interesting
to you because of your domain.
So going to those locations, trying to
find them, trying to connect to them,
I think that's really
a really good way to do it.
Another way is, at least I've
seen other entrepreneurs do it,
is going to alma mater.
Maybe finding angel investors or
venture capitalists that share
something common with you and one thing
can be they went to the same college.
Trying to find ways to
reaching out to them.
I think the key is, though, also
finding a warm introduction to them.
The last thing you want to do is
emailing them with no context and
with no person that can vouch for
you and or your business.
And that is something that you
have to find even before you
find the actual investor
that you reach out to.